io vi parlerò di questa nuova energia
contro i tumori che utilizziamo al cloud
di pavia un centro nazionale di
adroterapia oncologica di pavia dove
appunto si fa uso della dre terapia
ecco capiamo subito che cos'è
l'adroterapia per farlo usiamo un
modellino che tutti conoscono quello
dell'atomo negli ospedali italiani come
nel resto del mondo in generale si
utilizzano gli elettroni per produrre
raggi ics queste particelle sono molto
leggere si utilizzano delle macchine
acceleratrici e dunque circa un metro
che possono essere fatte ruotare attorno
al paziente in maniera tale del rag
harlow da ogni direzione in questo modo
si colpisce in maniera molto selettiva
il tumore
l'adroterapia invece utilizza i nuclei
hydros significa forte in greco perché
questi nuclei sono fatti da cork che
interagiscono secondo la forza forte e
in particolare noi utilizziamo il nucleo
dell'atomo di idrogeno è più semplice
che si chiama protone e il nucleo
dell'atomo di carbonio che ha fatto da
sei protoni e neutroni
qual è il problema che il protone
duemila volte più pesante dell'elettrone
e lo ione carbonio 24 mila volte più
pesante del dell'elettrone di
conseguenza le macchine acceleratrici
che servono per raggiungere in
profondità con la radiazione di tumore
sono molto più grandi
molto più ingombrante molto più
complesso e molto più costose ma ci sono
dei motivi per introdurre la do terapia
sostanzialmente sono due il primo a che
vedere con la precisione intrinseca di
questi tipi di radiazioni e nella parte
in alto della figura vediamo quello che
fa un fascetto di adroni che entra in
profondità nel tessuto vedete il
contorno in giallo del tumore
il fascetto la luminosità è indice del
danno che provoca vedete che provoca al
massimo del danno in fondo al suo
percorso componendo fascetti multipli si
può arrivare a conformare con precisione
dose sul volume tumorale non vedete dosi
all'esterno non vede non vedete dose
danno oltre e la dose nel canale di
ingresso che comunque viene attraversato
al di sotto dei livelli di accettabilità
dei tessuti sani
quindi l'estrema precisione il secondo
motivo per introdurre gli adroni e in
particolare gli ioni carbonio a che
vedere con la qualità dell'irraggiamento
il fatto che lo ione carbonio è un
grande distruttore
quindi se io arrivo in profondità nel
punto corretto li distrugga tutto quello
che trovo perché la densità di danno è
tale che produce delle rotture multiple
della catena del dna che non sono
riparabili dalla cellula dalla cellula
malata e di conseguenza curo i tumori
che sono radioresistenti che
costituiscono circa il 5 per cento di
tutti i tumori
ogni anno in italia si trattano a circa
240 mila casi di tumore ecco vedete il 5
per cento un numero significativo di
persone che possono beneficiare di
questa tecnica
ecco le tecniche che utilizziamo pavia
che abbiamo sviluppato per quasi a sono
delle tecniche innovative ne esistono
poche al mondo esistono solo altri
cinque centri 2 in germania uno in
austria sul nostro progetto
1 in giappone e uno anche in cina quindi
la scelta del ministero della salute una
dc quindicina di anni fa di introdurre
queste tecniche è una scelta innovativa
e una scelta che ha portato la sanità
italiana all'avanguardia in questo
settore e ad oggi alcuna lo abbiamo
trattato oltre 1.800 pazienti due terzi
di questi con ioni carbonio ed è stato
un crescendo continuo l'anno scorso
abbiamo trattato circa 500 pazienti
il target di quest'anno e superare le
600 unità e questo è avvenuto dopo una
prima fase un triennio fino alla fine
del 2013 in cui abbiamo dimostrato di
saper controllare queste particelle per
curare i pazienti attraverso appunto
questo processo di marcatura ce e del
dispositivo medico pena o quali
patologie abbiamo trattato adesso non
voglio che voi cerchiate di leggere i
nomi
ma voglio solo farvi capire lo spettro
la diversità delle patologie che sono
oggetto di cura con la terapia dove
stiamo facendo esperienza stiamo facendo
anche statistica proprio per dimostrare
che queste tecniche sono all'avanguardia
sono positive per i pazienti
parliamo di tumori della base cranica
testa collo tumori lungo la spina
dorsale pelvici tumori particolarmente
aggressivi come quello del pancreas e
col del fegato tumori piccoli come
melanomi oculari dove la precisione
importante così come nei tumori
pediatrici dove serve risparmiare i
tessuti del bambino che sta crescendo
ecco cerchiamo di capire se otteniamo
dei risultati positive ci sono
ovviamente per dire terapia stata
positiva dobbiamo seguire il decorso
della malattia cioè trattare il paziente
puoi chiamarlo per delle visite in
periodi successivi fino a cinque anni
dalla trattamento iniziale ed uno dei
parametri e quello del controllo locale
il tumore cresce nel tempo curando lo
dobbiamo cercare di arrestarne la
crescita o addirittura fanno scomparire
in tre pazienti su quattro trattate al
ko il controllo locale c'è quindi è di
successo come tipo di trattamento il
secondo indicatore a che vedere con la
precisione un parametro che è associato
alla tossicità del trattamento per i
tessuti sani e vediamo sia la torta in
alto è lato si sta appena al termine del
trattamento quella in basso dopo che sia
un follow up
vediamo per la tossicità più grave g4 e
g5 sono molto contenute e meno del 2 per
cento quindi vuol dire che
effettivamente la tecnica è precisa e
risparmia al meglio i tessuti sani
circostanti il tumore
ecco cerchiamo di vedere alcuni esempi
di queste di queste patologie che
trattiamo a sinistra vedete il caso di
un osteosarcoma un tumore che si è
sviluppato su una delle vertebre la
vertebra c1 vedete che tutto barbie kato
attorno all'osso questo paziente non è
curabile
non è curabile chirurgicamente neanche
con la radioterapia convenzionale perché
distruggeremo il midollo vedete
nell'immagine in rosso la deposizione di
dose ottenuto
raccoglie adroni conforma benissimo il
tumore e risparmi al midollo quindi
questo paziente può continuare a fare
nessuna svolgere le sue funzioni a
destra uno dei casi elettivi il cordoma
della base cranica una massa importante
in look e vedete all'interno della testa
trattata con ioni carbonio e dopo 10
mesi il tumore scomparso mi perdonerete
per la crudezza dell'immagine che segue
ma questo evita un po un'indicazione
anche della diversa tipologia di
trattamento di un paziente trattato per
melanoma mucoso con ado terapia sinistra
è trattato per la stessa patologia con
chirurgia a destra la qualità di vita
la terapia indolore nel caso della do
terapia quindi il paziente che viene più
volte più giorni per il suo trattamento
che dura in media pochi minuti ci sono
soprattutto tempi di preparazione
ecco il paziente continua a svolgere le
sue normali funzioni guardate cosa è
diventata invece la chirurgia dall'altra
parte quindi per certe patologie
l'adroterapia può cambiare il paradigma
di trattamento
poi ci sono tumori particolarmente
aggressivi come quelli del pancreas
le statistiche che stiamo raccogliendo i
trattamenti che stiamo raccogliete i
risultati sui trattamenti dicono che
otteniamo dei valori di controllo locale
della malattia che sono dieci volte
quelli abituali questo giustifica anche
degli studi clinici che stiamo portando
avanti che stiamo iniziando in
collaborazione con dei tedeschi con i
giapponesi degli statunitensi proprio
per vedere se questa modalità è la
migliore per trattare queste patologie
che sono patologie anche particolari
perché il tumore del pancreas si muove
con il respiro del paziente
quindi qui dobbiamo introdurre tecniche
molto sofisticate che sincronizzano la
deposizione della dose quel fascetta che
vi ho fatto vedere nel inizio con la
posizione del tumore ciò che sono adatte
a seguirlo nei suoi movimenti legati
alla respirazione precisione tumori
molto piccoli i melanomi oculari sono
delle sono dei patologie elettive per
l'adroterapia confronto
e in collaborazione con il politecnico
di milano in università di pavia l'infn
gli ospedali dall'iri nt di milano
abbiamo sviluppato un sistema robotico
che controlla la posizione della pupilla
del paziente lo mette dove serve per
curare quella patologia ed è anche
attento a verificare che non si muova la
pupilla durante il trattamento se lo
facesse si interrompe in automatico il
trattamento queste tecniche sono delle
tecniche completamente nuove che sono
state sviluppate qui al cloud di pavia
per la prima volta nel nel mondo e da
ultimo ma non meno importante
significativo
l'applicazione della proton terapia sui
pazienti pediatrici sono pazienti che
hanno lunghe aspettative di vita quindi
dove importante anche essere precisi per
non dare la dose a tessuti sani che poi
possono avere dei problemi durante la
fase di crescita
ecco il confronto tra quello che succede
nel trattamento di un medium lo glass
toma dove si era già tutta la spina
dorsale in alto a destra con protoni e
in basso a sinistra con raggi ics la
quantità di dose date tessuti sani con i
raggi xe può essere causa di recidive di
tumori secondari questo va assolutamente
evitato ecco vi ho spiegato razionale vi
ho detto anche fatto alcuni esempi di
patologie abbiamo adesso a vedere come
si producono questi fasci di adroni ecco
quel metro di acceleratore lineare che
negli ospedali i normali cene sono 350
in italia viene utilizzato per produrre
raggi ics qui è diventato una
circonferenza di 80 metri di lunghezza
che si trova qui a pavia qui vicino 25
metri di diametro composto da migliaia
di componenti molto molto sofisticate
il video che segue vi consente di così
avere un attimo il feeling di quello che
succede all'interno della macchina il
fascio che circola compie circa un
milione di giri in mezzo secondo
in questo mezzo secondo percorre una
distanza di quasi 30.000 km
in questi 30.000 km acquista la sua
energia acquista l'energia che serve per
arrivare in profondità nel paziente con
una velocità massima che dell'ordine due
terzi della velocità della luce arriva
sul paziente quindi 200mila chilometri
al secondo arriva sul paziente per
colpire in profondità il tumore il
paziente è allineato all'interno della
sala di trattamento su dei lettini
connessi sistemi molto sofisticati per
siccome viene più volte dobbiamo
riprodurre la posizione del paziente
ogni volta in maniera molto precisa
quando parlo di precisione intendo sotto
il millimetro in maniera tale che possa
poi irraggiare sempre con estrema
precisione il tumore stesso ci sono
ovviamente dei sistemi computerizzati
dei software che gestiscono il tutto che
mi permettono gli permettono mi
consentono di curare in maniera molto
performante questa un'immagine
un'immagine del cnao qui qui a pavia
ecco questo schema rappresenta lo schema
dell'alta tecnologia come come si
sviluppano i circa 200 metri di canali
magnetici in cui il fascio si trova a
percorrere partendo dalle sorgenti fino
alle tre sale di trattamento che abbiamo
vedete in ciascuna in fondo a destra
avete un lettino un fascia orizzontale
nella sala centrale c'è anche un fascio
verticale sono tecnologie che sono
proprie dell'ambito del lavaux tran di
laboratori di fisica fondamentale come
il cern di ginevra ma qui sono portate
alle estreme conseguenze dei concetti
fondamentali per poter curare dei
pazienti quindi sono anche più
sofisticati certi sistemi proprio per
garantire sicurezza efficienza
affidabilità e manutenibilità in un
ambito ospedaliero
se il sincrotrone quindi questa macchina
circolare di 80 metri e il cuore della
tecnologia del cnao il cervello e il
sistema di distribuzione della dose
sistema cosiddetto di scansione attivo
sono quei rivelatori quelle
quelle quei sistemi di misura delle
qualità del fascio che lì sono
schematizzati che misurano la posizione
il profilo e il numero di particelle che
compone ogni singolo fascio fanno in
modo che la macchina produca una certa
energia per arrivare a una certa
profondità e quando sono in profondità o
di fronte una fetta del tumore e poi
queste questi rivelatori guidano due
sistemi magnetici uno orizzontale uno
verticale e vanno a dipingere la fetta
tumorale fetta tumorale dopo fetta
tumorale dipingendole deposito in tutto
il volume del tumore
il danno la dose che voglio per curare
quella patologia
ovviamente quando penso ad un fascio
molto preciso devo stare attento a
posizionare il paziente con altrettanta
precisione e quindi all'interno della
sala di trattamento ve l'ho già mostrato
in precedenza ma qui vedete un filmato
che mostra come si comportano come si
sviluppano i movimenti dei diversi
sistemi abbiamo un sistema robotico un
lentino pantografo che permette di 6
gradi di libertà di posizionare al
meglio il paziente
abbiamo delle telecamere infrarosse quel
infrarossi quelle sistemi neri che
vedete sullo sfondo e stanno scendendo
adesso dei tubi raggi ics ortogonali che
permettono con i raggi ics di vedere
all'interno del paziente se il tumore
sta nella posizione che era previsto per
il suo trattamento
ecco vi ho parlato molto di tecnologia
vi ho parlato molto di sistemi
innovativi ha ovviamente la ricerca e il
secondo pilastro della nostra attività
quindi cura da una parte ma ricerca
dall'altra questo viene fatto in
collaborazione con molti enti in
particolare con l'istituto nazionale di
fisica nucleare con cui stiamo
sviluppando una quinta linea di fascio
che andrà a servire un'area dedicata
proprio alla ricerca e in realizzazione
sarà completata alla fine di quest'anno
in maniera tale che dall'anno prossimo
li effettueremo delle dell'attività di
ricerca e di sviluppo
quali sono gli ambiti in cui facciamo
ricerca sono molteplici e non ho certo
il tempo di esaurirli qui ecco vi do
così un po il senso di un paio di questi
uno a che vedere con la radiobiologia
vogliamo sviluppare dei sistemi dei
biomarcatori che sono associati alla
terapia che ci permettono di capire se
abbiamo colpito tutte le cellule
staminali tumorali
perché sono l'avessimo fatto avremmo
delle cellule rimaste che possono far
ricrescere il tumore
quindi questi sono degli indicatori
essenziali per noi per capire se stiamo
dando la cura nella maniera corretta
un altro ambito di ricerca e quello
dello sviluppo di rivelatori per la
prima volta con queste particelle
noi siamo in grado di capire se stiamo
effettivamente dando il danno
dove si trova il tumore perché queste
particelle entrando nei tessuti fanno
dei processi nucleari ed emettono dei
segnali se noi ricostruiamo questi
segnali con degli strumenti particolari
riusciamo a verificare se abbiamo dato
la dose dove effettivamente serviva sono
degli strumenti molto potenti ci fanno
vedere per la prima volta nella storia
della radioterapia dove ho dato il danno
ecco quello che è stato sviluppato al
crowne e grazie ad un ad un gruppo di
persone è un insieme di collaborazioni
molto esteso gruppo di persone che hanno
professionalità diverse sono circa 115
persone che vanno dalla bio ingegneria
alla radio alla l'oncologia dalla
radioterapia alla fisica degli
acceleratori all'ingegneria ecco sono
delle sportive diverse che hanno che
sono di fatto la parte più importante
del cnao
grazie a loro si sviluppa la formazione
grazie a loro si sviluppano le
collaborazioni internazionali e
nazionali
grazie a loro siamo anche richiesti e
collaboriamo lo sviluppo di altri centri
nel mondo ecco io direi che il tau è
veramente un esempio virtuoso di
esportazione di competenze all'estero
che rende diciamo che è un fiore
all'occhiello se vogliamo sia della
sanità che della ricerca italiana
ecco voglio concludere il mio intervento
con l'immagine dell'ortensia che tra
l'altro magari poi avete visto sulle
pensiline dei bus in questo periodo è
un'immagine molto molto significativa
molto artistica che ci dice appunto di
questo essere vivente con un piccolo
difetto che però possiamo curare con
queste trattamenti di alta precisione
sulla parte di destra ci sono i
riferimenti per contattarci per entrare
in contatto per approfondire la
conoscenza di quello che facciamo e
ovviamente anche siamo molto saremmo
molto lieti di ospitarvi quattro volte
all'anno effettuiamo durante dei fermi
macchina programmati anche delle visite
al canale e quindi siete anche i
benvenuti se volete venire a trovarci e
vi ringrazio per la
attenzione
[Applauso]